but here's something that apparently is
crazy in the eyes of the detroit lions i
talked about this at length last hour
when it was a report from bernie
smilovitz of wdiv4 in detroit the report
the lions are in talks to trade matthew
stafford and there's been some reaction
to trade talk of matthew stafford on
instagram by his wife kelly
suggesting that california would be
a preferred destination if the lions are
indeed done with matthew stafford and
obviously the la chargers right now
don't have a clear-cut starting
quarterback tyrod taylor's on the roster
and
they probably are going to be looking at
external options especially because
you've got to sell this team in la and
all due respect to tyrod taylor he's not
selling the team in la cam newton would
sell the team in la tom brady would sell
the team in la matthew stafford would
help sell the team in la but in fairness
to the lions and and i'm not really
shocked by the denial even if you're
going to trade the guy you have to deny
it you can't come out and say shireen
we're trying to dump this guy please
call us we're desperate you have to say
we're not going to trade him just like
the jaguars said they're not going to
trade jaylen ramsey until they did but
bob quinn the gm of the lions has told
dave burkett of the detroit free press
that the story is 100 false but it's out
there we've seen reaction to it from
kelly stafford and like anything else
like we did with jalen ramsey last fall
like we did with otto beckham jr last
march we just got to sit and wait and
see what happens
that's exactly right mike you never know
what's going to happen with these things
i do know if you change head coaches are
you change quarterbacks you better have
somebody better that you know you're
gonna get so let those tom brady to
detroit rumors start because if they're
gonna trade matthew stafford again
they've got to have somebody better than
matthew stafford that they have in mind
to take over his quarterback this is a
really good quarterback i think if we
started listing quarterbacks we're
probably going to have him in our top 10
and so who are you going to replace him
with and obviously the natural name
there would be tom brady and and maybe
that's what they end up with but i think
they're crazy if they trade him and they
don't have somebody in mind to get it
quarterback because who who are you
going to have at quarter this is the guy
who's thrown for 5 000 yards in his car
in a season in his career
yeah you're right if you're going to
move on from one guy you better be sure
that the next guy is going to be even
better especially at a time when
ownership has made it clear
that
it's up or out this year for matt
patricia and bob quinn and they've also
made it clear that they're listening to
the fans that they hear the fans
criticism and complaints well if they
dump matthew stafford
and the next guy starts slowly
the criticism and the complaints are
going to get more and more loud forcing
ownership to do something in 2020. so
you know one of my big takeaways when
martha firestone ford came out and said
that patricia and quinn are safe but for
2020 my takeaway was matthew stafford's
going to be back this is not the year to
change quarterbacks you better make the
most you can out of a guy who is one of
the best passers in the nfl get him
healthy get him on the field let him do
his thing and hope that you can put
enough good players around him to turn
this thing around and get to the
postseason i think doing it with a new
quarterback even if they could somehow
lure tom and giselle to detroit and i
don't know maybe you can lure tom there
i don't see
all due respect to detroit i don't see
gisele living in detroit or indy or
other you know non-coastal cities that
have football teams that could use tom
brady but uh you if you're gonna upgrade
you better be damn sure it's an upgrade
shireen
yeah absolutely this is a guy he only
played eight games last year but he
still threw 19 touchdowns and only five
interceptions and i know they had a
losing record but the quarterback was
not the problem matthew stafford was
playing it was the other pieces around
him i think this is a team that's pretty
close to being a really good team and so
if you are going to change at
quarterback you better be sure that guy
that you're getting in is better than
matthew stafford and there's only a
handful of those guys in the nfl so a
team ready to win now you're changing
quarterbacks it doesn't make sense to me
and here's the other side of it as well
trading matthew stafford would result in
a 32 million dollar cap charge for the
lions this year they already are going
to carry 13 million in dead money for
past bonuses
but his salary is 7.8 million workout
bonus of 500 000 8.3 million in cash 20
million in change cap number if you keep
him if you move him 32 million hits the
cap this year and you got no matt
stafford to show for it that's another
reason to not trade him but you're
flipping around if he were available
you've got
8.3 million this year 10 million next
year 13 million in 2022 that's a damn
attractive contract for a team that
would be looking for a quarterback i
mean if he's in play he's at least
bringing back a first-round pick for the
lions don't you think
oh probably more than that and and i do
think he the quarterback chaos you were
talking about the other day this would
really throw it into quarterback chaos
because i think there are a number of
teams that would be interested in
matthew stafford because they feel like
that he could step right in and take
them to that next level a team that's
one quarterback away
absolutely i'm going after matthew
stafford depending on what the cost is
yeah and uh here's the other thing too
if there weren't teams contacting the
lions before yesterday
there would be teams contacting them now
and this is the time of year where all
of these scenarios play out right we saw
alex smith traded
in theory not officially from kansas
city to washington super bowl week two
years ago you can do deals now they're
not official until march the 18th so
this is when
teams who are saying what are we gonna
do at quarterback well you've got an
entire landscape of options trade free
agency and and that's why you know the
tampering really gets going at the
scouting combine the tampering's
happening now tom brady's agent is
lining up the interested teams now other
quarterbacks that are going to be
available they know what is and isn't
out there now if there are other teams
interested in jameis winston and his
lasik improved vision
they're going to know about it now this
is when it's all happening this is when
the general managers are finding out
what are my options what does each one
cost and then they try to make a quick
decision and get the guy they want when
the time comes to make it all happen but
it look again and and i need to be even
more fair to bob quinn he didn't just
text 100 false to today briquette of
detroit free press he texted 100 false
with two exclamation points but but
again
we've seen this before and i feel bad
for somebody who actually is telling the
truth when they say 100 false when it
comes to trade talk because you're going
to say the same thing
if it's not 100 false you can't say yes
we're trying to trade this guy because
there's a chance you're not going to be
able to trade him for what you want and
you're going to keep him and once that
cat's out of the bag shireen you can't
put it back in
yeah uh tony dungy's the only guy i
think uh coaching wise or gm that that's
never lied to me you can trust what tony
dungy says outside of that they all lie
and so you i you know if he's telling
the truth good form i think matthew
stafford's probably the quarterback for
that team uh but again you have to wait
and see like you said based on what
we've seen over the years with guys
saying oh no he's not on the trade block
and a few weeks later the guy is
somewhere else the player is somewhere
else so we'll wait and see on this one
but again if if the lions are going to
do this they have someone in mind i
don't think they're just trading matthew
stafford uh or thinking about trading
matthew stafford without having an
option behind him ready to go and i
don't think it's a quarterback on that
roster that they trust
well and they have the third overall
pick in the draft so they could have
justin herbert or tuatanga via low i
mean they're in position to get one of
the top three quarterbacks because they
hold pick number three if that's what
they're thinking but again that doesn't
mesh with this idea that we got to win
now or there's going to be big changes
in detroit
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights from nbc
sports